why did mrs. D'Amato turn red she saw
mr. green pea watching adventurous
movies is always a fun experience
we are always mesmerised by the awesome
visual effects most of us are aware that
they are created by using a green screen
while shooting the movie but ever
wondered how this works and out of all
the other colors why are green colored
screens used mostly can we use other
colors let's find out imagine a person
who wants to teach some astronomy
lessons by showing fancy stuff in the
background all she does is add a green
screen in the backdrop how does this
help her well the answer lies in the
technique called chroma keying it's a
process carried out by various computer
application software's what exactly do
these softwares do let's understand with
our example in our video we want stars
and planets in the background
currently the whole background of a
video is just green so we tell the
software to remove the green color from
each scene in the video this makes the
background transparent now the job is
simple the software fills the
transparent background with an
astronomical scene the final result we
get is the combination of the
character's video footage with the
astronomical background this is the
chroma keying technique it's basically a
technique used to remove a specific
color from an image and replace it by
some other image
now that we've understood what chroma
seeing is can you tell me why the green
color is specifically used think about
it well to know that let's understand
with the situation here instead of the
green screen say we use a brown screen
as the background for a character now
obviously in the chroma keying process
we will remove the brown color from the
background notice what just happened
that's right when we remove the brown
color from the background the same color
tone from our character is also removed
we can now see that the result isn't
something what we want alright what if
we take this color as our background
again in the post-production we get an
absurd result this gives us a hint
doesn't it yes for the background we
have to choose some contrasting colors
that do not affect our skin tone or hair
color and which are those colors that
are not contained in our skin tone the
natural skin tone of the human body
doesn't have green and blue colors the
same goes with our natural hair color do
you see any shades of green and blue
colors I doubt it
so by default green and blue screens are
used in the backdrops but usually we
prefer green screens more often than
blue why is that the answer lies in the
digital cameras they are designed in a
way we see colors what does that mean
our eyes are more sensitive to green
color than any other color and digital
cameras have sensors that capture the
green color accurately so green being
highly luminance is easier for computer
software's to identify and remove during
post-production another reason is that
the green screen requires less lighting
setup than the blue screen also subjects
are likely to wear blue outfits more
often than green ones
it's very difficult to avoid blue color
outfits but what if the person wants to
wear green outfits well in such rare
cases the blue screen comes to our
rescue all right consider this
challenging situation we want to create
an action block seam of two characters
with some adventurous background here
one character is wearing a green outfit
while the other one is in a blue outfit
what should we do here do we have to
shoot characters with their respective
green and blue backgrounds separately
and then merge them together during
post-production or can be used both blue
and green screens together to shoot the
scene or is there any other better way
this is your cue box to explore let us
know your findings in the comment
section below do share this video with
your friends and press the bell icon to
get notified whenever we upload a new
video be curious and happy learning
[Music]